LANCE ALERTSON: My name
is Lance Albertson.
I'm with the Oregon State
University Open Source Lab.
I'm the director.
And I run the lab.
The Open Source Lab
provides infrastructure
hosting for medium to large
open source Foss projects.
So we host projects like
drupal.org, Apache Software
Foundation, Python
Software Foundation,
and 150 other
different projects.
The Open Source Lab has been
a mentoring organization,
I think, since 2005 or 2004.
I don't remember which.
And I have been a mentor
with OSL since 2008.
The Open Source Lab experience
and GSoC 2013 was great.
We had four great students.
We have two students
working on a project
actually at the lab
called Ganeti Web Manager.
And one of them was working
on a new visualization
tool for virtual machines
within a virtualization cluster.
Another student was working
on improving the installation,
the ease of installation
of the project,
which is a huge
problem we've had.
So it'll make a
really big impact.
And that particular
student actually
has been with the program
since GCI in 2010.
So he's been GCI one year and
GSoC two years in a row now.
We had another student
at a Ganeti provider
to the Vagrant Project,
which we use quite a bit
at the lab, which is great.
And then the final student
worked on an Android
application dealing with
conferences, open conferences.
So we had this
Android application
we created a couple years
ago we'd kind of abandoned.
There's a lot of
forks on GitHub.
And so we are trying to
merge that all together
and updating it.
At the Open Source
Lab, I'm really
hoping that we'll eventually
do more infrastructure related
coding project with GSoC.
We've kind of been stuck on
the same one for several years.
And it's great.
But it's kind of nice
to have some variety.
So we have some other ideas that
we've just never gotten around
to we need to flush out before
we can make it a GSoC program.
If anybody wants to get
involved in the Open Source Lab,
just hang out on
our IRC channel,
pound OSUOSL on FreeNote.
It's a great way to get started.
Check the bug tracker
code at ocosl.org
and see any bugs in the
Gateway Manager Project.
And just comment to check out
the code, that sort of thing.
There's a variety ways.
We're trying to figure out a
volunteer system for people
actually helping
the lab in general.
We just haven't
figured that out yet.
But we're still trying to.
Hopefully we'll get that
going within a year.
My personal reward with
GSoC is seeing the students
that we've had
over the years grow
that keep coming back and
seeing them excel and move
and figure out what they
want to do in the world.
So we get to do that
locally in Oregon at OSU.
But being able to do
the same thing globally
is really a big thing.